Woody I definitely have to ask you an
individual question
um you are going to be joining the SNL
five timers club uh with your upcoming
uh hosting gig uh what does it actually
mean to you to join the exclusive Club
it means one more than it did last time
no I don't hey it's really it's very
exciting I can't say I I'm trying not to
think about it because I'm so I get
nervous because it's live I just get
nervous about it and particularly the
monologue so uh so far all all it means
is nerves but but at the end of the
night Saturday night the 25th I think
it's going to mean some happening gonna
be exciting yeah are you going to be
proud of you no no I would not okay come
on over you know what I I
I had something to say and it's better
if I don't is this thing up I love that
she's censoring herself
this is incredible it was yeah if you
heard what she said the last interview
but never mind about that let's go on I
was just gonna say that I really
sincerely thought the two of you were
fantastic together and I I knew I was in
for a good ride because the opening
scene alone like the banter between the
two of you in the bedroom and leaving
I'm like oh they're very good together
um so can you sort of talk about did you
like when did you realize you guys were
going to be really good together I
intimidated him right away so I felt
like this is gonna be a home run
she did and then I just that's daunting
yeah belittling him throughout the shoot
and that made me feel better about
myself and then I feel like that came
across on screen but in fact you know
the very first scene we shot together
was a kind of intense emotional scene of
which you know there's there there's a
few in the movie but at least a couple
and uh and she just brought her a game
and I was like oh boy I gotta step up
here oh my God she's such a great
actress I'm not she's so not just a
great actress and emotionally available
but like and then when you're in the the
fun funny scenes like this that first
scene it just uh you know no one
delivers better than her I mean other
than me but I probably shouldn't have
said that it was uh it was very fun
making him laugh and he just it's like
he's a perfect scene partner we just I
think we had we actually were having fun
together which I think is always helpful
I love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a film
um and I'm curious for both of you what
do you think soon to be fans of the film
would uh be surprised to learn about the
making of Champions you've said several
times today it felt like we were on a
playground every day and it's so true we
just showed up I mean we had so much fun
not just making it but every time we cut
we were on a basketball court we had all
these amazing new friends that we were
hanging out with who wanted to know all
about us and wanted we wanted to know
all about them and we just were
legitimately having a good time it also
really helps to be shooting a movie away
from your hometown we were in Winnipeg I
wasn't rushing home to make dinner for
my kids we got to just like live there
and relax and just be together and spend
time together Madison who plays
Cosentino had a birthday and she had
the birthday party of the century in a
hotel room in Winnipeg we had so much
fun it was a huge dance party we just
legitimately had such a fun time Dave I
want you to come by the woods and hang
out with me and let's fire up a holder
sir just send me the info and I will be
there okay today tomorrow
seriously congrats and uh have a really
have a good day thank you all right see
ya